hello there Karen warden would film
courage the radio show and we just got
finished with our interview with mr.
Thomas were ready I am a bluebird and
when we were in studio we asked you what
is your kryptonite and you mentioned
money sure that's kryptonite for a lot
of people as well can you touch on what
happens or the dilemma that filmmakers
face when they put all their money into
the production of the film and then when
it comes to finish the film
post-production there's nothing left
sure um well like I was saying before
like 11 issue that we had with I on the
Bluebird was that we didn't plan for
distribution or marketing or I mean to
some extent post-production partially
because like you know like the kind of
you know the general consensus when
you're making a movie is like you put
everything in front of the screen every
time that you can that you have for your
film it should you should you know
especially when it's like at that level
you should try that you know let it let
it show on screen try to put everything
into the movie that you see and what I
would say to that haven't gone through
that process now is instead of
compromising that number just know that
you need more than that like you like if
you have a hundred thousand dollars for
a movie you should raise two hundred
thousand dollars from movie like there's
one thing that like that we were you
know we started to realize is you know
like during the production you put you
know you find the best DP that you can
for the money the best gaffer that you
can for the money the best equipment
that you can get for the money the best
you know actors that you can get for the
money that you have to work with it then
and then when you get to post Russian
you're like you know well I can edit so
all I did or I can read them you
so I I'll read the music which yeah
that's true I could like you know and i
got like i said i got into filmmaking
because i wanted to write the music and
but like when it came to like editing
like I had an editor to the and I had
somebody do the sound a guy there was no
way I was going to go through that
process on my own partially because you
get you know you get too close to what
you've done and then you know you would
make decisions that that at the end of
the day would compromise the integrity
of the maker could because your mirror
you're married to what you very shot and
then but you know and then once you get
so you know you start kind of cutting
corners a little bit around the
post-production phase and then once the
movie's done then you're like you know
then there's no money left and you're
like well you know we don't need it like
you know like the sales agent you can't
you can't afford the best sales agent
for the money because you didn't
allocate any funds for you you know like
marketing materials like a team to
design all that stuff like the
promotional materials the trailer is the
posters like any of that stuff and when
you end up having is a movie and nothing
else there's no you have no no way and
so you start cutting you know that that
what you do is you really are interred
compromising the whole film by not
giving yourself the you know are
planning in advance for for everything
that you would need after the movies
done like deliverables there's a lot of
things that people forget about which
luckily for me like I had access to a
lot of ways to get those without paying
for it but like that like if you don't
have the access that stuff that can cost
you anywhere like to like 35 grand to
get all the different tapes and the dubs
and all this you know yeah like it's it
get it gets expensive and the point I'm
trying to make is that plan for budget
for it like if you have a hundredth if
you think you can do your movie for a
hundred thousand dollars instead of
compromising a hundred thousand dollars
to pay for the stuff and post and like
you
what happens after that with marketing
and prints and all that stuff you know
add that to your budget like people like
in you like you know I think the likes
one thing that you know I know at least
a lot of filmmakers kind of make the
mistake of is that they don't they think
that the more that they asked for the
harder it's going to be to get and you
know having like you know starting on
the next project and I kind of got going
through this process once before I've
kind of started to realize that that's
not necessarily true the the biggest
problem that people have with with
investing is the plan not being smart
enough and it's not being like doesn't
have everything that it should so when
someone you show a plan to an investor
and it's like yeah well we can this way
for a grander you know hunter grander
200 read that you know depending on who
you're talking to you that may not be a
lot of money to them but what Betty but
if you don't have you know your budget
and it doesn't have all these things in
it that that deal with the film after
the fact they're not they're not going
to be like oh well that's that's not
that much money they're not going to
think that they're right they're gonna
be like why would I spend 200 thousand
dollars on this movie if if there's no
way for anybody to see it because then
that's how they're going to make their
money back you know or if they're not
even concerned about it just comes
across as its kind of amateur where it's
not really really put in place and I
think that's like you know for that's
probably most one of most important
things I learnt off of doing I'm the
Bluebird is is that kind of whole
process of dealing with with the end
game and and you know not not going up
to investors like investors like if
they're going to spend money on
something they're going to spend money
on it like you know or they have money
too they want you might as well give
them the best the best information that
they can have and also give yourself the
best opportunity to make a successful
film
and get it out there we made that
mistake because we didn't know about
that stuff like I i hadn't i was like i
said i was kind of in school to time so
my primary focus was finishing the film
and you know we didn't beating playing
for all that stuff because we hadn't
gone through the process performed so I
mean this is kind of parsley like what I
would do if I was going to redo it I
guess if I was going to go back and
start over I would find the extra few
hundred thousand dollars and and be
honest people people respect honesty as
much as like it's sometimes scary to ask
for you know 200,000 more dollars like
for a movie or however much you're
trying to make it rain before the end of
the day it's it's it's not that much
money you'd like two words you know if
you spend it right you'll be fine I
think that as long as we could perhaps
that's important but yeah platform
you